bueno pues las conclusiones es que
siguen sin estar de acuerdo y hoy el
secretario en estado norteamericano ha
sido muy claro con los rusos les ha
dicho que si de verdad no tiene ninguna
intención de atacar a ucrania ni ahora
ni más adelante pues que reciben
directamente todas esas tropas que
tienen amasadas al otro lado de la
frontera ucraniana hay que recordar que
estamos hablando de más de 120 mil
soldados según los servicios de
inteligencia
ucranianos el presidente ruso vladimir
putin ha hablado hace unos minutos para
constatar que eeuu no está tomando en
serio las propuestas rusas y que
esperamos del encuentro entre boris
johnson y selenski
la verdad es que el presidente es el
esquí se siente bastante cómodo con
boris johnson que en los últimos días
está proponiendo una intensa agenda de
sanciones contra rusia si decide
finalmente llevar a cabo algún tipo de
injerencia en ucrania hay que recordar
que en las en los últimos días es el
esquí el presidente ucraniano en algún
momento ha pedido más tranquilidad eeuu
que no esté mandando todo el rato
mensajes de pánico hoy tv con boli
johnson y espera contar con el apoyo del
aliado británico si realmente rusia
decide dar un paso adelante en ucrania
en los próximos meses